the Russian Revolution in about three
three seconds here the idea is this
Society is deeply unfair they're rich
and Powerful the 1% we could call them
the 1% control everything the
aristocracy the Zar uh they have all the
resources they and everybody else is
essentially a slave and what we need to
do is we need to create what they call
the dictatorship of the people they
created a bloody Revolution they killed
the zard the royal family murdered them
all executed them all um and then began
to go after everybody else everybody who
had some kind of status or power in the
pre-existing structure for example in my
grandmother's case they had a horse that
was enough for them to be considered
wealthy people came to the house with
guns kicked them out of the house took
all their property and exiled them to
Siberia my grandmother who was a little
girl
remembers her little brother uh begging
for food on the way and they didn't have
enough food and he stared to death on
the way